jetzt kommen wir zu einem anderen Thema
und zwar kommen wir jetzt ja Bela zu
einer verbotskultur wie kam es richtig
ausdrücken worüber du heute Abend
sprechen willst auf jeden Fall geht es
wieder um die Grünen ja es geht um die
Grünen vor allem geht es um den
Landwirtschaft und vor allen Dingen in
diesem Fall um unseren
ernährungsminister um Cem Özdemir der
hat ein neues verbot sich ausgedacht und
heute und dass der anders noch mal
bekräftigt der hat nämlich gesagt es
muss ein Verbot gegen gegen
diejenigen die mit zuckerhaltigen
Nahrungsmitteln werben also gegen Cola
gegen McDonald's
Gummibärchen natürlich auch gegen
Ketchup Hersteller alle möglichen wohl
zu viel Zucker drin ist Hamburger
Hersteller Hintergrund ist und das
stimmt die deutschen Kinder werden zudem
jede sechste Kind in Deutschland ist
adipositiv also besser bekannt als
Übergewicht nennt man Adipositas das ist
doppelt so viel wie den 90er Jahren und
Fett glaube ich Gehalt ist ein echtes
Problem aber woher kommt das und kann
man das wirklich durch Verbote der
natürlich die
werbeindustriebeschneidungen Verbot an
Werbeindustrie verändern ich bin feste
Überzeugung nein es trifft den falschen
willst du mir sollte man in seinem
eigenen Gesetzeswerken nachgucken denn
es gibt ein Gesetz was jetzt fünf Jahre
in Kraft ist das ein unglaublichen
Zucker und Dickmacher hier in
Deutschland zulässt in der EU das ist
die sogenannte
high fructose
hfcs my Sirup auf gut deutsch isoglukose
genannt auch das sind Ballaststoffe oder
das sind Zuckerersatzstoffe die sofort
in den Körper gehen die nicht satt
machen anders als der herkömmliche
Zucker und die bis dahin Jahrzehnte
verboten waren in den USA in den 70er
Jahren gebraucht deswegen gehen die
Amerikaner alle so auseinander jetzt
haben wir die Folgen in Deutschland ich
finde chem Özdemir sollte zurück zu der
Regelung diese ISO Glukose zu verbieten
und nicht mit verbotskultur
Werbewirtschaft und andere hier
praktizieren
Herr Schubert Ernährung hat ja auch
einen großen Einfluss auf die Psyche was
halten Sie denn von dem Vorstoß von
jamast
also ich bin da gar nicht so dagegen mal
darauf zu gucken wie in unserem Land in
unserer Gesellschaft ernährt wird und
mit welchen mit welchen
gesundheitsfaktoren hier gearbeitet wird
was ich ein bisschen paradox finde ist
dass wir uns die letzten drei Jahre
nicht unbedingt um die Gesundheit der
Menschen die gehört haben ich sehe das
ganzheitlich ich sehe es eben nicht auf
einer Reihen somatischen Ebene sondern
ich sehe es so dass ich mich da auch
fragen muss warum essen in die Menschen
so viel und warum möchten Sie denn so
gerne zuckerhaltige Dinge essen ja das
heißt ich wäre eher auf der Seite dass
ich mir sagt guck mal doch mal warum
essen denn Kinder so viel Schlechtes und
warum wollen Sie denn das und warum sind
sie suchtkrank also die Frage würde ich
mir Stellen einfach eine erweiterten
Rahmen spannen um diese Frage und nicht
ähm wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
dann möchte jemand etwas tun für die
Gesundheit der Kinder ja und das sehe
ich aber ganzheitlich ich sehe es eben
nicht auf der stofflichen Ebene in Nahr
ungsbestandteile raus zu lassen sondern
ich frag mich eher war aber was treibt
in unserer Gesellschaft Kinder dazu sich
so schlecht zu nehmen so ungesund zu
sein das ist für mich die Frage lass uns
einmal reinhören sie mir das eigentlich
begründet was er hat
durchschnittlich 92 Prozent der
lebensmittelwerbung die Kinder im
Internet und TV wahrnehmen ist für
Produkte wie Fast Food Snacks und
versüßigkeiten deswegen wollen wir ein
kindergerichtete Werbung für
Lebensmittel mit zu viel fettzucker und
Salz gesetzlich einschränken und bei
Kindern hört das Spaß auf auch der
werbespaß meine Damen und Herren ja aber
zuerst die Kinder zuerst geimpft
mitgehenbasiert Stoffen sorry das ist
verlogen auf Corona kommen
gehen ist ein gutes Hinweis weil diese
Zuckerersatzstoffe sind aus gehen
manipuliert Mais die dazugesetzt werden
und es ist natürlich zu kurz gesprungen
als du mir gesagt dass das nur gegen
Süßigkeiten und dergleichen ist bei
dieser Zuckerersatzstoff ISO Glukose ist
mittlerweile in fast allen Lebensmitteln
drin warum bei Zucker süß schmeckt weil
das gleichzeitig den Appetit anregt weil
es nicht sättigt anders als der
herkömmliche Zucker und weil auf diese
Art und Weise in die auch die Kosten
runter gedrückt werden können also zu
sagen wir müssen das Werbeverbot für
diese Sachen beschränken oder gerade
Verb durchsetzen und und nicht zu gucken
wo ist dieses Zeug noch drin das ist in
Energy Drinks in Brot zum Teil das das
wird das Problem nicht ändern und das
meine ich mit verbotskultur
züncht man etwas über man müsste an den
Kern der Sache gehen und das ist für
einen ernährungsminister viel zu
weniger was bedeutet es denn eigentlich
für den Standort seit Standort
Deutschland wenn die ganzen Werte fehlen
weil die schalten ja auch übrigens
Werbung in Medien für die Medien ist das
sind Tiefschlag gar keine Frage und ob
man darauf berücksichtigen muss oder
nicht ich meine das ist ein bisschen
schwierig für mich zu beantworten da bin
ich sozusagen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aber aber es gibt schon einiges zu sagen
Verbote allein bewirken ja nicht dass es
zurückgeht der Konsumer das möchte ja
sagen nicht also
viel gesoffen worden wie in der Zeit der
Prohibition also und das ist ja ein
guter Beweis dafür dass man durch
Verbote nicht als reduzieren kann die
Appelle nutzen offensichtlich nicht dann
weiß ich nicht ob man nicht überschulen
über über eine größere erziehungspakete
ja wirklich die Leute dazu bringen kann
ihren Kindern das zu essen zu geben was
sie auch brauchen natürlich also meine
Tochter sie hat Salat weil sie nur grün
sieht ja wird sie schon wirklich schon
ein ausschlaggeben aber geht's mir
genauso aber aus politischen Gründen
okay
nein aber man muss dann schon wieder
reden und ich glaube ich bin in der
Zwischenzeit noch fünf Kindern also
gesegnet mit viel guten Ratschlägen für
Kinder man kommt schon manchmal durch
man muss ja nur ein bisschen bemühen
deswegen weil in der Super RTL oder dis
oder so wie keine Werbung mehr erscheint
und auf der Plakatwand neben der Schule
nicht mehr für Cola geworden darf also
das wird das eigentlich meine Moderation
übernommen weil du hast ein super
Übergang zu Herr herrles Thema heute
abend
kulturelles Ding ja der das geht den
Staat nichts an was die Leute essen was
will der Stadt denn noch alles verbieten
und wer in der Ernährung nur eine Frage
der Nahrungsaufnahme der richtigen
Mischung der der Nahrungsstoffe sieht
und nicht ein kulturelles Ding der macht
einen einen ganz grandiosen Fehler und
ich glaube dass der ötzte mir das
unterstelle ich ihm jetzt einfach mal
dieser grünen Ideologie unterliegt der
den Menschen verbessern will den
Menschen verändern will und da ist eine
Leitkultur und Essen ist Leitkultur es
ist wahrscheinlich das was die leicht
Kultur am meisten ausmacht dann ist die
Leitkultur diesen Leuten im Weg und dann
wollen die nicht dass man sich auf gute
alte deutsche Art den Magen voll schlägt
ja also jeder ist für seine Gesundheit
selbstverantwortlich da brauche ich
nicht eine Internet zu mir und überhaupt
keine Bundesrepublik und kein Staat
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie